i love uh on this last burner album
burner put you what what was that lineup
of that record it was like you conway
benny the butcher jenny
uh was styles on there or something it
was it was a lot of it was it was real
rap
that was real rap burn when he sent that
to me and i'm saying and he was telling
me so i ain't gonna lie to me and burn
we had a you know a little brief
conversation
about how a couple [ __ ] sizzled me on
that [ __ ]
you know did you know who was gonna be
on it you know i'll just be getting
sizzled like that right right right
right right but uh nah he most
definitely hit me to who was going who's
gonna be on it but i don't think i got
to hear these verses if i got to hear
they versus i'd have blacked out blacked
out um i made an attempt but after
hearing they verses i was like oh yeah
yeah he even called me too like bro i
think brett got you you know i ain't
gonna say no names
uh yeah you you that's actually one of
my favorite projects is the the slimy
individual [ __ ] that [ __ ] is crazy me
too i function with that burn another
person you know what i'm saying we just
get he's a great a r too i feel like
he'll be putting people on records oh
you're the truth how you know what how
you know
that's his no that's his gift i i swear
i know bro you pinpointed that he i feel
like burn be putting people together
that like
[ __ ] he's one of the illest that i just
told that [ __ ] i need him to a r my
whole project
beat selection
he just banged that cancer yeah he just
beat cancer so you know he was really
supposed to anr this whole project
fought me at least a couple songs on
that [ __ ] but uh dude you know
i'm saying me his is is is against the
[ __ ] he had going on uh
he missed this one but on the double
back i'm most definitely gonna lock in
with him on my next project and help him
do his dougie because like you said just
even with our project like them is some
of my favorite songs yeah like the fact
he put like uyg and logic on a record
and that [ __ ] was hard as [ __ ] like who
would ever have thought like let me put
logic on a song with mozzie and yg you
know what i'm saying it came out insane
razor yeah fella
super crazy